he had me at hello uh in the uk version
of the office
many moons ago and uh also
on fargo and sherlock and now
in the tv series breeders which
premieres
monday march 22nd at 10 eastern on fx
with two back-to-back episodes you can
stream it the next day on
hulu it's season two of breeders and the
star of that fx series martin freeman
the emmy award-winning actor
and so much more back uh right here on
the rich eisen show how are you martin
yeah very well thanks fetch yeah i'm i'm
good how are you i am doing well
um i have three children uh ages 12
10 and seven um i i
honestly don't mean to turn this into
any therapy session um
i love them dearly but i see the point
of your show
martin you know um i i see the point of
your show that uh
despite the love they can drive you
little nuts
right yes absolutely and i think maybe
even because of the love they drive you
nuts because i guess
who you know who is anyone you know who
you don't love who can drive you that
crazy
um i think that that um the people that
push your buttons most in the world are
the people who you love most you know
who can push them more than your parents
or your kids
yeah yeah um yeah i understand i've got
i've got this sign right here in front
of me it says best dad ever i have it on
my desk here
so i i use this as a shield uh to
basically say
they drive me crazy sometimes you know
yeah of course yeah i mean i think if if
we're alive and if we're present
with our kids uh that's gonna happen
because everything
you know laughing happens hugging
kissing
you know all the loving stuff is going
to happen alongside
moments where you lose your mind with
each other you know and they're
allowed to lose their mind with you and
you with them you know that that's um
a part of a three-dimensional family
life really which is where
it's where the show came from i just
sort of i got sick of the sort of
instagram
version of uh life that is uh
projected but it also kind of seeps into
people's actual conversation now you
know grown-up
adults sort of want to project this
thing that
um you know just be being a parent is a
blessing and a gift and i feel so
blessed and it's amazing
it's just wonderful well yeah it is
absolutely those things it is a blessing
and a gift then it's also the hardest
thing you will ever do if you want to do
it
well um so that's where it comes from
really it comes you know
myself simon blackwell and chris addison
the creators of the show were you know
we're all fathers and we all love our
children to distraction of course but it
doesn't mean you don't recognize
um the other side of it that um isn't
advertised
on instagram you know yeah i i mean i i
play a poker game
every week or certainly i did
pre-pandemic now i do it online um
and before my firstborn was born
uh one of my great friends who's a
father uh sits at the table he goes
congratulations you're gonna have your
first kid
but they ruin everything they ruin
absolutely everything think about just
absolutely everything television
commercials movies your own vacations
your sleep periods
and so i'm i'm wondering what your own
children think about this show breeders
that is again
hitting season two on fx coming on
monday what do you
what do your own kids think about it
doesn't it i mean they really and they
not only love it but they they are they
are aware that they are sort of the
um the inspiration for it so now they're
hitting me up for royalties
they i think they they want a background
deal from dad is that what you're saying
this is what you're saying
they're 12 and 15 and i think it started
as a joke but i think each time it comes
up
they're a bit more serious uh well no
dad this this show wouldn't exist
without us
right so what was chunk of the rock you
know
um no they love it they really like it i
mean
you know their mum's an actor their
dad's an actor so they like watching
their parents
work and i think that's i think they're
very proud of us which is
lovely for me um but they also of course
recognize
you know that the character i play paul
is a father who loves his kids and who
occasionally shouts at them
that's their home life you know so they
recognize all kinds of things all kinds
of bells are ringing for them
each episode of breeders um with with
episodes that
you know the things that happen that are
not specifically from my
they might not be from my actual
experience
but they will be from either my or one
of the writers experience
because all the writers are parents um
so it's all kind of it's all the stuff
that
i mean you mentioned not making this a
therapy meeting earlier you know
our development and you know creative
sessions in the early days of this show
were like father's
uh you know father's sessions in therapy
because we were just all admitting the
worst things we had done or had happened
to us and with us as parents and
you know stuff that might be um mined
for comedy you know because as we know
you know the flip side of all this stuff
uh of of tragedy and trauma is is comedy
you know like you only have to look at
it through a slightly different prison
and you can laugh at it um or at least i
hope you can yes absolutely
martin freeman here uh on the rich eisen
show i i'd love to go down your career
you know i obviously don't have all that
much time but i i do want to start
with the fact that long before here in
america
and we fell in love with the office and
uh you were part of the uk
office you were playing the gym role
named tim
uh how did you get fixed up with ricky
gervais
for this and did you know that you were
part of something that was going to be
such a phenomenon
at the time martin freeman i i've done a
sketch show
uh for the bbc called bruiser in 1999
and ricky was one of the writers for it
he contributed material to it and and i
met him and we got on very well we made
each other laugh and i thought i thought
his
his material was genuinely like properly
funny
in a way that not everybody not
everybody is probably funny
um and i guess he remembered me for
you know for auditions for it for his
show the office that he was doing
um and so yeah that's kind of how i met
him
but you know i auditioned for it first
of all actually i auditioned for
gareth which is the english version of
the sort of dwight character yes um
and then and then as i was leaving the
room they said actually why don't you
read the tim
so thank god i did because i was better
suited to that one
and yes i i didn't know it was going to
be as big as it was
but um i knew i was very proud of it
because and i showed it to a couple of
friends of mine and
one of my cousins who's a been a
stand-up for like 25 years and
he i showed it to him and he said this
this is really really good you know and
everyone i showed it to before it was on
tv
just thought it was yeah it was the
detail of it the sort of
the exact precision of it was you know
it was just so beautifully observed and
ricky of course was an amazing sort of a
central
character in it um yeah i i didn't know
it was gonna be huge but i knew i loved
it
did you ever connect with chris
krasinski uh on
on the role in any way shape or form or
no oh do you know what i
i didn't i've still never met john
krasinski
worked with his wife emily uh but no
i've never i've never met john kozinski
i think he's brilliant you know and i
got to really like the show after after
feeling slightly resistant about the
american one
why why were you resisting well because
i think pretty naturally if you know
someone just did you know
a version of your show in britain
and called it something close to your
name and said it's going to be like a
better british version
in the hell are you what do you think
you know right um so yeah i was just
thinking that way
but but not for very long and then when
i watched it i
yeah i went straight through i thought
it was it's a great show
martin freeman here on the rich eisen
show uh fargo
i mean for you to take on that role as
well in the television version
of the show um how how often how how did
you
nail down that that flat minnesota
accent how did was that is that the
toughest accent you've ever had to
nail down in your career yeah to do it
properly yeah to do the
to try and do it properly and not do an
snl version of it right
uh you know um but not to send it up but
to sort of give it its due
and some you know to give it a bit of
reality
which i hope i did it was it was i i'd
nailed it with a lot of work
yeah it was it was a lot of work i had a
couple of sessions before
i went to canada to do it and then there
was a voice coach
um on sets all the time because you know
most
of the people in the show needed some
help with that accent and uh
yeah it was it was a lot of work i mean
whenever i'm doing a show at the moment
where i'm doing an accent i just stay in
the accent
all the time that i'm doing you know and
always on set i'm just in the accent so
it just becomes a
sort of muscle that you work but apart
from anything else i just i knew that
that
i read the first episode of fargo uh
that noah hawley had written so
brilliantly
and i just thought oh man this is too
good it's just too good not to do
um when it gets to that scene between
you know mine and billy bob thornton's
characters
it's so beautifully done um and just the
chance of working with him
as well you know it was just in that
close proximity it was a it was a real
pleasure that job was one of my
favorites
well that that that season of fargo is
one of the greatest seasons of
television i've ever seen i mean
and i'm again i'm not just saying that
because of you we've had colin hanks on
the show many times i know him
personally
uh obviously you know that was uh truly
amazing before i i do let you go i know
you've got a lot uh
on your your plate with this show today
uh chadwick boseman gets
nominated for an oscar posthumously i
would love to give you the floor on your
experience of
of being with him on the set of black
panther
martin well he was just you know he was
a real
gent is the truth you know he was softly
spoken he chose his words carefully
uh he was a workhorse you know i mean he
worked harder than
you know than it's possible to imagine i
think and i even i thought that at the
time and of course no one knew he was
ill so you know it used to make me laugh
the amount he was
you know the amount of work he was
putting in on set and offset at the gym
you know i remember talking to him and
just sort of laughing at the
his workload now you know knowing what
we know and what he was probably going
through at the time in 2017 and
it's pretty heroic it's pretty heroic
really
um to to do the good job that he did
on set the way he led that cast as well
um as an actor and as an individual
human
um and what he was battling with is it's
um
yeah i admire him even more than i did
and i certainly admired him
in life but uh yeah as i say
posthumously finding out what we found
out
about how he was for the amount of time
that he was ill it's sort of
unbelievable that he managed to do what
he did
you must have been gobsmacked when you
learned so you learned what just the
rest of us
when he passed away that he was battling
cancer on the set of black panther
in like no one and this is the thing i
spoke to a couple of
people at marvel and i was like did you
really not know really no one knew that
like no
nobody here i mean it isn't it's
incredible really it's a sort of
it sounds almost like a myth um
of what you know human beings are
capable of when they
when they allow themselves to you know
push themselves that far
yeah i mean no one knew i was absolutely
gobsmacked but apart from anything else
of course it's it's a
a lovely bloke dying um way too soon
you know never mind the acting bit or
the legacy bit you know he's that's a
a person who is a family member and a
loved one and a husband and
that's the ultimate tragedy of course
you know for those of us who worked with
him it was you know
awful awful news and shocking news but
you know obviously your thoughts are
mainly with the people who you invest
and love them
uh and then before i let you go martin
freeman um last one for you
my my wife loves love actually but um
she only fills in for me on this show
i'm out here so i'm sitting in the chair
today i got to ask you about sherlock
are you is that ever you can do another
one you and benedict cumberbatch
ah i don't know i mean to be honest no i
was i was told yesterday
uh that last week ben had been quoted as
saying possibly so
i guess it depends who asks us and at
what time
funnily enough i had a dream yeah i did
have a dream about doing sherlock
last night i dreamt i was back on the
set of sherlock in a very strange setup
but um
that sounds like an episode of sherlock
to be very honest with you
it does yeah i mean i suppose every
everything is possible you know it's a
show that i'm very proud of
i think it's fantastically written
beautifully directed um
you know and obviously it was a hit with
many many people and i know why they
loved it because i love it but
um as with all things uh it has to be
the right time and for the right
reasons for for benedict myself steven
moffatt and mark gates the
creators you know we all have to be in
the right place okay well again
on behalf of my wife she loved you in
love actually as well
martin i mean she that that is a remote
drop movie for her she can't uh
she she must watch it to its conclusion
whenever she sees it
i love that it's beautiful she she loves
it actually you know
there you have it okay thank you martin
i honestly i could really bend your ear
and i've just really only scratched the
surface of your career i do hope
uh this is the first of many times you
appear on this show and
i look forward to seeing season two of
breeders on fx
monday march 22nd 10 eastern and fx has
two back-to-back episodes to get things
started and you can catch
new episodes the next day on hulu thanks
for the call martin
thanks rich you're the best that's
martin freeman right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here